[Music]
we compiled a top 10 list of our most
anticipated horror films in 2019 here
are the frightening films were most
excited about in order of theatrical
release 2019 is looking pretty scary us
in 2017 Jordan Peele redefined the
horror thriller with his directorial
debut get out
this year he goes full-on horror with
his follow-up us the opening night film
at South by Southwest stars Black
Panthers Winston Duke and Lupita Nyong'o
reunited as a married couple with kids
who encounter evil doppelgangers of
themselves the breakout success of get
out made Jordan peel one of the hottest
new directors to watch the cast rounded
out by Elisabeth Moss of The Handmaid's
Tale and an eerie trailer complete with
a throwback remix of loonies I got five
on it has us dying to see it when it
opens on March 22nd Pet Sematary Mary
Lambert's 1989 Pet Sematary made us
think twice about burying Fido in the
backyard and in April starry eyes
directors Kevin Kolsch
and Dennis wide Meyer will try to do the
same the directing duo will close out
South by Southwest with the premiere of
their take on Stephen King's horror
classic starring Jason Clark and Amy
seimetz as the unsuspecting couple who
moved to a sleepy town in Maine with
their children and discover a mysterious
burial ground behind their home with
John Lithgow on hand this is one of the
more exciting Stephen King movies we've
got coming down the pipeline
the curse of La Llorona this new horror
film centers on the Latin American folk
legend liya Dona the spirit of a weeping
woman whose cries bring misfortune to
anyone who hears her sets in 1970s Los
Angeles the film stars Linda Cardellini
as a social worker who ignores the
warnings of a troubled mother and
discovers she and her family may be the
target of supernatural evil James Wan
the genius behind SAW and the conjuring
is in the producers chair this film
should provide a fresh cultural twist on
the traditional ghost story when it
opens on April 19th child's play
director Lara's club burg updates this
80's horror classic for the 21st century
complete with a new take on the killer
doll Chucky this time around a young
mother played by Aubrey Plaza gifts her
son a high-tech Buddy doll without
realizing the toy isn't exactly
kid-friendly
ditching the Voodoo storyline this
remake goes full black mirror as buddy
rejects his programming and develops a
mean streak original child's play
creator Don Mancini is apparently not a
fan of this new concept but the
franchise has an aged well and an
updated reboot with plaza and red-hot
star Brian Tyree Henry could be exactly
what it needs scary stories to tell in
the dark executive producer in horror
master Guillermo del Toro selected
fellow monster lover Andre over doll as
the man to lead an adaptation of this
popular children's book series the film
combines multiple stories telling the
tale of a group of kids who must unravel
the mystery behind a wave of horrific
deaths a longtime passion project for
del Toro
even casual fans will agree he's got a
keen eye for terrifying imagery
judging from the early glimpses we've
gotten the shape of water director and /
doll have nailed the look and feel of
the books so prepare to relive your
childhood trauma
August 9th midsummer ari Astor writer
director of the insane horror film
hereditary is back in the director's
chair to terrorize us with a new
nightmare
it features Lady Macbeth's Florence Pugh
and will Poulter from Bandersnatch as a
couple who travel to a quaint Swedish
village only to be trapped in a bizarre
and dangerous competition with a pagan
cult we're giving some serious wicker
man vibes from this one and we ain't
talking about the Nick Cage not the bees
mid-summer should be another atmospheric
chiller with some good freak out moments
see it in theatres August night it
chapter 2 the second Stephen King
adaptation on our list and EMU sketti
returns to direct the sequel of 2017
it's Bill skarsgård is back as penny
wise and the adult cast is rounded out
by some heavy hitters Jessica Chastain
James McAvoy and Bill Hader who has said
scars guards penny wise is even scarier
in person it Chapter two picks up 27
years after the losers club faced off
against Pennywise the clown now they're
all grown up and ready to return home
for the final showdown it chapter 2 is
arguably the most anticipated horror
film of the year and it's in theaters
September 6
dr. sleep that's right it's Stephen King
yet again but this time we finally get a
sequel to The Shining dr. sleep stars
Ewan McGregor as a grown up Danny
Torrance who uses the shining to help
rescue other children from a cult called
the true not director Mike Flanagan has
made a name for himself on movies like
oculus Ouija origin of evil as well as
Netflix's the haunting of Hill House
series Ewan McGregor is joined by
Rebecca Ferguson and Jacob Tremblay dr.
sleep is in theaters November 8th
[Music]
[Applause]
the lighthouse it's taken a few years
but director Robert Edgar's finally
comes through with a follow-up to his
critically acclaimed 2016 horror film
The Witch Willem Dafoe and Robert
Pattinson lead this 1890s period tale
based on seafaring myths about an aging
lighthouse keeper named old shot on 35
millimeter black-and-white film stock
and using 1920s and 1940s camera
equipment both Dafoe and Pattinson have
described how excruciating and wet it
was during filming which all means that
the lighthouse could feel like a
throwback to old school horror
filmmaking it's currently set to release
sometime in 2019 little monsters Oscar
winner Lupita Nyong'o plays
schoolteacher Miss Caroline who takes
her class on a field trip to a farm
close to a military experiment while
there a zombie outbreak occurs and Miss
Caroline must save herself and her
students earlier reviews out of its
Sundance premiere praising young goes
commitment to a role that could have
felt silly coming from someone else no
release date as of yet but little
monsters looks to make another strong
case for yong-go being crowned our next
screen clean what does your most
anticipated horror list 2019 look like
let us know in the comments
[Music]